[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission Anne surtout
pas manquer sur TV 78 si vous êtes fan
de sport local alors vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué je ne suis pas
Michael elmidoro il a affaire en ce
moment et c'est plus important que le
sport on le on le salue le présentateur
change mais la formule reste la même
comme toujours il y aura des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une bonne dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous installer en plateau ils sont en
pleine forme en ce début de printemps
présentation musique de cette magnifique
équipe plus forte que la dream team de
1992 à ma gauche on commence musique
c'est une grande sportive elle vit
également pour le sport elle adore faire
des 10 km dans la forêt de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye elle a fait
beaucoup de basket aussi dans sa
jeunesse elle nous vient de la ville de
Poissy Audrey Lepère nous fait l'honneur
d'être avec nous dans cette émission
bonjour Audrey comment allez-vous ça
fait un moment qu'on voyait pas dans le
si on parlait sport préparation footing
préparation semi là le Paris
Saint-Germain pour dimanche prochain
donc en pleine forme en pleine forme
pour aborder ces beaux jours même si en
ce moment la météo est plutôt morose on
a eu quelques semaines de beau temps
pendant les vacances et là c'est vrai
que c'est moins bien en ces derniers
jours juste en face à ma droite musique
c'est un véritable guerrier un monument
de cette émission il est préparé comme
jamais il commence à être bien bronzé il
revient de vacances d'ailleurs il va
faire des ravages sur les plages cet été
on n'en doute pas notre gladiateur
Pierre Chevalier du Rugby Club de
versaillite avec nous bonjour Pierre
salut à tous salut les amis comment ça
va salut Greg ça va très bien
effectivement petit j'ai profité des des
rares moments de d'éclaircie et de
soleil qu'on a eu sur les 10 derniers
jours c'est vrai que ça a pas mal changé
depuis j'ai mis mon costume de lumière
vous êtes habitué à Michael présentation
ça va pas trop changé les choses on est
habitué on reste entre amis pas de
problème
de la culture sportive on repasse de
l'autre côté musique il est plus connu
que Michael Jackson ou encore Elvis
Presley grâce à sa présence sur ce talk
cette émission fera encore plus
d'audience que le couronnement de
Charles III mesdames et messieurs coach
Jean Miss excentrineur du Rugby Club de
plaisir du plaisir Rubic club même c'est
dans l'autre sens c'est avec nous
pendant une heure comment ça va Jean ça
va très bien bonjour à tous bonjour
bonjour Audrey
impeccable vraiment impeccable on vient
de vacances
un petit peu de repos ça fait pas de mal
et malgré la pluie tout va bien le
soleil dans la tête
on termine de l'autre côté musique
dernier chroniqueur de cette émission si
on parlait sport c'est un petit nouveau
même si maintenant il commence à
collectionner quelques cas piles devient
titulaires discutable il crée sa légende
à chaque émission ilonore déjà sa
septième sélection dans ce SEPA sport a
dit si nous invitent au restaurant il
est responsable sponsoring chez Orange
en Île-de-France il adore le sport et il
est amoureux bien sûr de
si on parlait sport c'est Philippe
Baulac comment ça va Philippe bonjour
tout le monde bonjour Greg impeccable
impeccable on aborde la dernière ligne
droite des saisons de foot et de rugby
donc voilà donc intéressant alors on va
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
fédérale 2 de rugby ça va ravir nos
rugbymen en plateau ça faisait longtemps
qu'on parlait pas de rugby dans si on
parlait Sport Rugby Club personne aussi
la suite de l'aventure ou pas on
l'espère pour plaisir en Fédérale 2 nous
parlerons aussi aussi des tensions
autour de Messi et de son fameux voyage
en Arabie Saoudite voilà toute
l'histoire autour du Paris Saint-Germain
et de l'Argentin peut-être un divorce à
venir pour cet été et aussi des
dernières semaines difficiles pour le
football club de Versailles mais on va
tout d'abord parler box c'est la
nouvelle nous est parvenu dans les
dernières heures Maeva manouche mais en
terme à sa carrière elle l'a annoncé sur
Twitter je la cite suite à une blessure
à l'oeil causée par les combats je dois
mettre fin à ma carrière après 16 ans de
combat j'ai dédié une bonne partie de ma
vie à la box avec de nombreux titres
mondiaux les JO je ne garde que de bons
souvenirs alors l'ex élancourtoise de la
team Farrugia à 33 ans compte 22
victoires chez les pros dont 18 avant la
limite et deux défaites au point elle a
remporté cette titres de championne du
monde IBF des super plumes mais il y
avait on s'en souvient participé aux JO
de Tokyo 2021 où elle avait été éliminée
en dixième de finale dans les conditions
on se souvient un petit peu douteuses
par la Finlandaise Mira pas de Conan
c'était au point cette défaite déjà une
première réaction on aura l'occasion
dans un prochain si on parlait sport de
revenir plus plus longuement sur sur
cette carrière de Maëva ma douche
première réaction pierre à l'annonce de
cette retraite coûte chapeau déjà pour
le pour sa carrière et confirmation que
la vie des sportives et des sportifs de
haut niveau n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille elle a quand même duré duré
un bon bout de temps au plus haut niveau
on en a souvent parlé sur ce tableau sur
ce plateau avec le
cette participation aux JO et qui laisse
un gros good inachevé sur cette
désormais fin de carrière parce que la
frustration de sa carrière je pense que
c'est le cas on en avait parlé à
l'époque en disant que ça pouvait lui
servir pour rebondir et continuer à
essayer de durer mais c'était à essayer
de durer et malheureusement bon ben là
le corps le corps dit stop on va dire et
mes grands coups de chapeau sur sa sur
sa carrière au plus haut niveau on en a
parlé souvent c'est vrai Jean sur ce
plateau vous la connaissez bien en plus
double profil de sportive et policière
dans la vie c'est un exemple à suivre
elle a faillite port drapeau on le
rappelle aussi aux JO de ce que je veux
dire elle est elle avait été hésité elle
avait failli être orthographe drapeau
lors des derniers JO ou c'est vraiment
une très grande sportive c'est
malheureusement les risques les risques
de de ce sport là boxe c'est c'est les
fins de carrière sont souvent dû au
corps qui dit stocke et c'est le cas
dans une famille RMC Sport que il y
avait un vrai risque de perdre son œil
tout à fait tout à fait donc là il y a
pas il y a pas de terre j'ai versé puis
quand même à 16 ans de Cézanne de
carrière ce type de champion du monde a
une belle carrière donc bravo et bonne
continuation Audrey
déjà une belle référence à sa carrière
professionnelle c'est vrai que 16 ans
c'est extraordinaire c'est vrai que
comme vous le dites double casquette et
c'est un exemple évidemment en fin de
carrière comme ça c'est toujours
compliqué de finir sa carrière sportive
comme ça bon c'est un peu frustrant mais
après c'est c'est un bel exemple aussi à
suivre peut-être pour les jeunes les
jeunes Chantal en tout cas
Philippe on va terminer avec vous sur
cette thématique
tout le monde l'a dit c'est une belle
carrière bon c'est faut savoir s'arrêter
il faut que faire comme on dit dans
d'autres sports aussi l'année de trop
parce que souvent on a vu des
catastrophes ça c'est sûr et surtout là
en plus ça touche quand même au niveau
des yeux et un œil c'est quand même bon
au mieux vaut mieux s'arrêter et bon
dommage c'est à un an des JO mais
peut-être que elle sera elle pourra je
veux dire au niveau des JO être
je sais pas enfin les commentaires par
rapport à ceci donc ça peut être aussi
voilà l'opportunité à un an des JO de
pouvoir voilà 36 ans 36 ans pour Maëva
ma douche je pense que c'est pas mal
de toute façon 33 33 ans c'est
33 ans ça rapproche à des à des
[Musique]
et c'est déjà l'heure de la
traditionnelle envolée alors j'ai
récupéré la présentation du Sep un petit
peu à la dernière minute j'avais déjà
préparé elle envolée donc je vais vous
en faire profiter qu'est-ce que vous en
êtes vous êtes prêts alors je vais vous
parler du Football Club de Versailles
souvenez-vous la saison dernière le FCV
nous a transporté tous ici nous tous ici
en plateau alors transporter Michael et
moi qui n'est pas présent aujourd'hui
jusqu'à Périgueux nous avions suivi le
quart de finale de la Coupe de France
contre Bergerac transporter aussi dans
l'euphorie vous le voyez avec ces
supporters jusqu'au porte de la finale
de la compétition en s'inclinant avec
les honneurs face à Nice dans le dernier
carré la saison parfaite pour l'équipe
amateur auréloé auréolé d'un titre de
champion en N2 et d'une montée en
Nationale la troisième division
nationale les lumières sont alors
braquées sur le Football Club de
Versailles mais deux investisseurs du
groupe fidu SimCity à la tête du club
fixe le projet atteindre la Ligue 2 le
plus rapidement possible et ils mettent
les moyens on a parlé du des différents
budgets au début c'était 3 millions
d'euros d'après nos différents confrères
on serait plutôt même autour des 6
millions d'euros de budget cette saison
des recrutements des joueurs
expérimentés et même internationaux
parfois le FCV a complètement changé de
dimension en l'espace de quelques mois
alors jusqu'à présent le rêve se
prolongeait les Versailles sont restés
en cours sur une bonne partie du
championnat pour arracher la promotion
en Ligue 2 dès leur première saison en
Nationale mais les 5 défaites depuis le
début de l'année ont enrayé la machine
victorieuse la dernière contre le Red
Star le 2 mai à Saint-Gratien a reléguer
l'équipe à la cinquième place au
classement à 5 points du lieu de tête
Martigues Concarneau le tout à 3
journées de la fin du championnat ça
semble compromis pour le FC Versailles
nous sommes satisfaits de la saison et
en train de préparer la saison prochaine
affirmer Christophe petit l'un des deux
investisseurs du club à nos confrères de
l'équipe un club ne peut se structurer
en un jour du jour au lendemain nous
travaillons sérieusement et le projet
avance pas de quoi paniquer donc et au
fond pour une première saison en
National avoir joué ça change jusqu'au
bout pour la monter est en soi déjà une
victoire mais le vernis à mon sens c'est
tout de même légèrement écaillé avec
ceux qui se trame en interne les guerres
intestines d'abord entre d'un côté
l'ancien coach Youssef chibi et de
l'autre l'ex directeur général du club
Jean-Luc Arribart citons également
Michael miché responsable du recrutement
et de la communication les relations
étaient glaciales le FC Versailles a
remercié Arribart et ce rêve en conflit
avec Michel dont le contrat prend fin le
30 juin il ne serait plus rémunéré
depuis janvier l'affaire sera bientôt
devant les prud'hommes il est aussi bien
sûr l'affaire Youssef chibi on s'en
souvient reconnu coupable d'atteinte à
l'intimité de la vie privée condamné à 8
mois de prison avec sursis pour avoir
filmé des femmes à leur insu mise à pied
par l'équipe yvelinoise l'entraîneur a
été remplacé par le Brésilien Chris la
question alors sur toutes les lèvres on
se les poser aussi en plateau ce remuage
interne allait-il affecter le groupe et
ont bien on est en droit de se le
demander après les résultats des
dernières semaines alors cerise sur le
gâteau le Football Club de Versailles
serait selon plusieurs médias dans une
situation financière extrêmement tendue
du principalement aux difficultés
actuelles du groupe fidu SimCity des
retards de paiement des prestataires un
loyer à très lourd à assumer du stade
Jean-Bouin pour les rencontres à
domicile et une masse salariale qui a
explosé en empilant les noms elle a
grimpé à 2,8 millions d'euros soit 43 %
du budget du club le secteur sportif
compte 34 salariés le secteur
administratif un seul donc on voit que
le club a eu du mal à se structurer
preuve peut-être que les propriétaires
ont voulu aller trop vite sans penser à
structurer le club au préalable du côté
des investisseurs on dément pour le
moment toute difficulté financière mais
les propriétaires chercheraient
actuellement des partenaires financiers
pour diversifier le capital du club voir
le revendre alors nous ne sommes pas
loin de la douche froide soyons honnêtes
après l'extase le FCV pourrait être
victime d'une sérieuse gueule de bois
qu'il faut éviter à tout prix pour
plusieurs raisons je suis un grand
rêveur vous le savez en plateau et je
veux continuer de vivre et à vivre ce
rêve éveillé parce que Versailles nous a
raconté une belle histoire la saison
passée les Français ont besoin de belles
histoires les temps sont difficiles la
prochaine pourrait être un jour celle
d'un deuxième représentant francilien en
Ligue 1 prenons-nous arriver pourquoi
pas et aussi pour que les Yvelines c'est
la dernière raison continue d'avoir leur
représentants dans l'élite du football
français bref il faut éviter le désastre
tout faire car j'ai le sentiment que si
le club est vendu si le club est et
lâché par le propriétaire actuel et bien
son millier de licenciés et ce club ne
s'en remettrait pas c'est mon avis voilà
je vous l'ai déjà avoir votre avis sur
sur cette envolée et peut-être vous
poser déjà d'ores et déjà une question
on va pouvoir prendre les petites
raquettes Vert et Rouge et ce qu'on peut
être déçu par la saison du FC Versailles
et je vous fais réagir également à
l'envoler
non non pour Pierre oui
on va faire un un petit duel entre
Audrey et Pierre on va commencer avec
Audrey peut-on être déçu de la saison du
FC Versailles je pense qu'on peut déjà
les féliciter sur sur leur jeu sur leur
développement aussi en termes d'équipe
en terme de développement aussi des
états d'esprit donc ça c'est mon c'est
ma raquette verte là où je suis
effectivement scandalisé c'est
effectivement sur le l'entraîneur du sel
chibi ou je suis vraiment scandalisée je
suis révolté et comment est-ce qu'on
peut aujourd'hui encore avoir ce type de
de problématique qui était qui a recruté
cette personne là donc je pense que pour
les prochaines années il va falloir être
encore plus vigilant parce que pour
Versailles c'est vraiment dommage
vraiment on était très satisfait d'avoir
un club dans les Yvelines en tout cas
voisins donc oui là-dessus ça reste une
une réflexion assez simple mais voilà
voilà mon tel esprit d'aujourd'hui
il a participé aux différents pontets du
club et c'est vrai que oui cette affaire
en dehors du sport nous a tous surpris
et c'est vrai qu'elle est tombée un
petit peu un petit peu comment dire par
surprise votre avis à vous pierre alors
moi c'est je rebond je rembobine sur
l'ensemble des choses qu'on avait pu
aborder et disserté sur le club du FCV
depuis le début de la saison dernière à
travers l'épopée en Coupe de France et
puis surtout sur cette saison là puisque
la question concerne la saison qui
s'achève avec une précision je pense
qu'on je pense qu'on a on a on s'est
emballé trop vite c'est-à-dire que avec
avec le
somme toute relative pression médiatique
puisqu'on en parlait ici on s'est
renseigné et puis il y a eu des
résultats mais il y a eu des résultats
qui étaient assez inattendus en début de
saison et donc on s'est emballé enfin
c'est mon avis je pense qu'on s'est
qu'on a on a cru que l'appétit ne venant
en mangeant avec les décisions qui
étaient prises et surtout avec le côté
le côté tactique et puis un facteur
chance aussi qui joue ça pouvait passer
dès la première saison en Ligue 2 mais
c'est vrai que les investisseurs
parlaient d'une montée le plus
rapidement possible en Ligue 2 même si
là ils sont revenus un petit peu sur
leurs propos et on dit que le plan était
plutôt sur 3 ans c'est ça et en fait
dans toutes les dans dans les dernières
semaines de communication et d'échange
il y a eu plusieurs articles justement
sur cette relative déception par rapport
aux fans aux fans du SCV et puis les
droits de réponse qui était aussi qui
était aussi
adressée notamment dans Le Parisien par
par les deux investisseurs les deux
co-présidents du FCV en disant il y a
pas périr dans la demeure on est on est
dans le rythme dans le rythme à trois
ans donc ma réponse est dire non pas
déçu puisque on a rêvé on a continué à
rêver après le après le la saison
exceptionnelle en Coupe de France de la
saison dernière manière et que cette
saison oui ils nous ont fait un peu
vibrer ils nous ont ils nous ont fait
rêver à plus haut mais n'oublions pas et
c'est pour ça que je réponds non
n'oublions pas que c'est leur première
saison en National qu'il termine 5e et
qu'ils ont ils ont joué les premiers
rôles pendant une bonne partie de la
saison effectivement en étant en premier
et deuxième ou deuxième et c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui nous a fait espérer plus
mais restons mesures restons en fait
mesuré et puis on va dire sportif et
fair-play en disant que ils ont ils ont
fait un très très bon premier exercice
en National et puis dernière chose je
pense à limite s'il peut y avoir une
déception c'est sur le côté
structuration et hors terrain
structuration ça a été un peu trop vite
il faut pas oublier que depuis le départ
le FCV a ce problème de stade qui pèse
de plus en plus lourd dans la gestion
dans la gestion du club où il y a un un
seul salarié dans le secteur
administratif tout est sur la partie
sportive donc pour le coup ça peut pas
marcher ou ça peut pas marcher aussi
vite aussi vite que ça et emmener les
fans du FCV et les spectateurs à
j'envoie un systématiquement on sait que
dans la durée ça marche pas non plus et
c'est que Paris c'est que une vingtaine
de kilomètres on parle là déjà de
l'année prochaine pour pour le national
de de Sano Saint Gratien de l'île
Chambly Le Mans on a parlé beaucoup de
Stan mais qui sont tous très très
éloignés donc là donc ça peut revenir
cette question revenons revenons à une
structuration dans la douceur et dans la
durée surtout de ce club réglons les
problèmes qui sont posés et là on
recommencera à rêver Philippe vous êtes
le juge de paix qui vous a convaincu on
rappelle aussi quand même que il y a eu
beaucoup de remue-ménage cette saison
donc finalement peut-être qu'au vu de se
remuage le point ce que tu es le taux
positif les deux les deux mon convaincu
parce que voilà c'est
je pense qu'ils étaient dans le début de
saison sur la dynamique de l'année
dernière de la saison précédente et
c'est souvent ça en fin de compte
lesquels souvent en foot ils sont ils
montent ils sont dans une belle inhabité
et ils font une première belle saison on
a vu même des clubs successivement
vraiment une belle saison et là j'ai un
peu peur que voilà depuis le début de
l'année toutes les affaires qu'il y a eu
bon le problème de terrain ça on en a
parlé déjà dans les autres dans les
autres émissions
comme je l'ai dit si on est de la
délocalisé
la plupart du temps ça marche pas c'est
il y a on a eu beaucoup d'exemples en
Île-de-France le résultat d'autres
encore qu'on a eu 6 maintenant la
deuxième représentant francilien en
Ligue 1 parce que c'est aussi le rêve en
Île-de-France
depuis le Racing le Racing qui est qui
avait été en Ligue 1 ça date ça date sa
date et c'est un peu Paris la région
parisienne n'a pas alors que dans tous
les autres un pays il y a 5 6 7 clubs
des fois c'est incroyable je veux dire
mais bon c'est j'espère que l'année
prochaine sera que ça va aller bon ils
vont perdre beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs
parce que comme on en a parlé la masse
salariale va vraiment diminuer et voilà
il faut repartir parce qu'ils ont des
bons jeunes aussi il y a une école de
une belle école de football il y a il y
a il y a du monde
déjà au niveau administratif la
structure déjà et après elle va se
suivra le côté sportif votre avis genre
alors pierre disait ça va peut-être
laisser le temps de travailler sur le
dossier du stade parce qu'il y a
plusieurs pistes on a parlé aussi
d'aller jouer au moins la saison
prochaine même près de Lille à
Villeneuve-d'Ascq c'est peut-être un mal
pour un bien de d'avoir d'être plus
progressif on va dire dans dans cette
évolution du FC Versailles depuis
progressif oui parce que
on constate à travers à travers cette
équipe que l'argent ne fait pas tout et
que on a beau mettre les moyens
financiers en oeuvre pour aller accéder
au niveau supérieur et bien ça fait pas
tout on voit bien qu'il faut structurer
et pas que structurer que sur le plan
sportif il faut structurer aussi sur le
plat administratif en bus avec on l'a
dit vous venez de le redire cette grosse
problématique et qui est le stade qui
est le stade et qui pour moi est le plus
gros problème du club et ça s'il faut le
résoudre à mon avis avant c'est le
dossier prioritaire parce que un stade
c'est la stabilité d'une équipe c'est on
se retrouve à domicile c'est le stade on
joue à domicile on est chez nous et
comme pour un sportif pour un club pour
tout ce qui entoure autour de tout ce
qui tourne autour du club
c'est la base et ça cette base c'est
compliqué de structurer et de former et
de faire évoluer les choses autour donc
réglons enfin qui règle d'abord ce
problème de stade qui à mon avis la
priorité et ensuite bon j'ai pas redire
tout ce qui a été dit je me fais une
belle saison pour moi c'est pas une
saison de décevante c'est un promu donc
une en plus une saison on le rappelle ou
il y a six décentes donc c'était aussi
le risque pour le FC Barça c'est une
belle saison une belle saison maintenant
il faut le temps de structurer le projet
de 3 ans moi je trouve ça beaucoup plus
lucide beaucoup plus
cohérent et professionnel mais mais tant
qu'ils auront pas réglé ce problème de
stade ça va les déstabiliser
complètement en tout cas il y a toujours
un stade du côté du FC Versailles même
s'il était pas homologué pour cette
saison nationale le stade Montbron a pu
voir très récemment un match dans ce
stade entre le Racing Club de France et
Rouen plusieurs milliers de personnes
dans les tribunes bon ça faisait
peut-être un peu mal au cœur de voir ce
stade qui puisse vibrer
une autre équipe que pour le FC
Versailles pour le FC Versailles on
précise juste que le prochain match ce
sera ce vendredi 12 mai sur le terrain
du Paris 13 de Atlético un derby France
une défaite et là les dernières espoirs
de montée s'envoleront mais très
rapidement au plateau on peut dire que
la montée c'est terminé mathématiquement
jouable mais qui mangeait mais quand on
regarde les derniers matchs et notamment
je pense au dernier contre le Red Star
nous allons prendre 3 le 3 0 contre un
concurrent à priori direct directement
la possibilité de monter donc là c'est
la dynamique qui est peut-être devant ça
ça tourne quand même que ce soit
Concarneau Martigues Dunkerque et le
même le reste là parce que comme on a
parlé tout à l'heure j'en parlais tout à
l'heure par rapport au stade le projet à
3 ans c'est un exemple concret reste ça
maintenant ils ont leur stade ils sont
en train de faire les travaux et tout
ils vont rester là ils ont été aussi à
Chambly ça a pas marché ils sont
descendu et là ils ont maintenant leur
stade et tout ils ont vraiment
exactement ce que tu disais exactement
on va parler un peu plus tard de
football avec le Paris Saint-Germain
également du remue-ménage en coulisse au
Paris Saint-Germain mais on va continuer
d'abord à parler de Versailles pour le
plus grand bonheur de Pierre on va
changer de sport on va parler de rugby
le RCV devait réaliser un exploit sur le
terrain du Creusot ce weekend c'était
même le weekend il y a deux weekends
pour pour le RCV lors des barrages de
fédéral 2 les Versailles diminué par des
absences n'ont pas réussi à faire de
miracle ils se sont inclinés 27 à 6 à
l'extérieur une belle saison tout de
même un pour verser on le rappelle promu
dans cette division de Fédérale 2
c'était une première historique pour le
Rugby Club de Versailles une saison qui
a satisfait les dirigeants en tout cas
on avait reçu un joueur et on avait reçu
également euh le manager de l'équipe la
question sur cette thématique est-ce que
on peut être quand même satisfait de
cette saison versaillaise en rugby
large oui et on va donner la parole
quand même à notre versaillais du Rugby
Club de Versailles pas pourquoi on peut
être satisfait pierre de cette saison du
RCV évidemment on est content parce que
Chauvin d'une part et réalise d'autres
parts c'est-à-dire que là on vient d'en
parler pour le football à Versailles sur
un niveau bien supérieur sur le niveau
amateur en fédéral 2 qui est vous l'avez
rappelé une une première historique pour
le pour le Rugby Club Versailles qui
n'avait jamais atteint ce niveau ce
niveau de jeu amateur c'est une
satisfaction parce que on a on agit un
petit peu dans l'inconnu en fin de
saison qui avait été euphorique avec
deux chances pour monter et finalement
c'est après le tirage sa moto grattage
juste après au grattage de ballons
contre Vincennes et puis il y a cet élan
et cette dynamique qui nous a porté
toute la saison dernière qui continue à
produire des effets sur cette sur cette
saison qui s'achève et effectivement
avec la la réforme des différentes
poules on a eu un nivellement par le
haut avec avec justement cette
possibilité d'accéder de la Fédérale 3 à
la fédérale 2 pour la première fois de
notre histoire et
c'est une satisfaction pour cette saison
pour sur l'état d'esprit le jeu pratiqué
le l'envie et ce qui a été montré au
stade à porschefontaine ou sinon sur les
autres sur les autres terrains
franciliens avec des supporters des
enfants de l'école de rugby qui ont une
équipe fanion maintenant qui est qui
évolue à bon niveau une école de rugby
qui est assez qui est assez global
de former le plus de joueurs possibles
capables de jouer en première et c'est
le cas sur toutes les feuilles de match
en première en réserve et évidemment en
équipe senior 3 puisqu'on a on a trois
équipes seniors c'est d'avoir le plus de
représentants possibles formés par le
club et ça c'est la vraie satisfaction
de l'ADN et de la culture du rugby à
Versailles maintenant sur ce match
contre il y a une petite frustration
parce que sur le scénario du match il y
a peut-être quelque chose à jouer c'est
ce que disait les acteurs la première
joie ça a été se qualifier dès la
première saison on Fédérale 2 c'est ça
le c'était c'était le cadeau bonus et
ce qu'on peut dire peut-être maintenant
à posteriori et à froid c'est de dire
que l'influx était parti on avait on
avait réalisé plus que l'objectif parce
que l'objectif de base au départ on le
disait par prudence c'était le maintien
en général 2 voilà donc on a on a eu
plus que prévu avec la qualification il
nous manquait oui il nous manquait du
monde en termes de joueurs dans les deux
groupes d'ailleurs parce qu'on jouait
sur les deux tableaux la réserve c'est
qualifiée aussi en barrage de de fédéral
B donc voilà très belle équipe du
Creusot très belle équipe de Pontarlier
contre pour le pour la réserve voilà
peut-être que l'influx l'esprit n'y
était plus pour aller chercher un petit
peu plus loin parce que la saison était
déjà bien dense et puis elle avait elle
avait amené son lot de satisfaction oui
les gens on est au-delà des esp parce
que Pierre parler de l'objectif maintien
en début de saison finalement il y a eu
cette sixième place en saison rigueur
qui a permis de se qualifier pour les
barrages on est au-delà des espérances
de ce début de saison pour on le
rappelle une équipe qui évolue pour la
première fois Fédérale 2 tout à fait
au-delà mais avec une lucidité quand
même qu'il ne faut pas oublier où il y a
eu cette refonte des des des niveaux à
la mi saison de la fédération et la
création d'une d'une Nationale 2
qui a fait que
la fédérale 2 aujourd'hui n'est plus la
fédérale 2 d'hier et tant mieux c'est à
dire tant mieux pour les clubs comme
Versailles qui sont montés à
l'intersaison ça leur a permis justement
de bien figurer dans le championnat et
de pouvoir accrocher une qualification
chose qui à mon avis
techniquement la saison dernière
n'aurait peut-être pas eu
j'aurais pas eu la petite possibilité
mais tant mieux c'est fait et tant mieux
donc là ils sont sur une voie dynamique
on parlait de structure juste avant avec
le football de Versailles là c'est une
preuve d'une bonne structure que ce soit
autour de des équipements qui qui
possède parce que les instants de
maléfiques autour de l'école de rugby
pierre à parler autour des seniors ou
bon ça je sais que il dit qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de de gens issus du
club moi je sais surtout qu'il y a
beaucoup de joueurs qui sont allés
chercher à l'extérieur
l'un des plus gros budgets de la poule
de Fédérale 2 est-ce que c'est vrai
alors
de cette couleur de la poule de la poule
quand même que effectivement ils ont des
joueurs issus de la formation mais ils
ont quand même une de l'équipe de
joueurs qui sont allés chercher à
l'extérieur mais le recrutement a été
très intéressant très ciblée voilà très
ciblée et performant puisque les
résultats sont là donc c'est une bonne
structure une bonne cohérence pour un
club qui est en plus d'avenir parce que
ils ont des objectifs ils ont des
ambitions et se mettent les moyens de
leurs ambitions donc je pense quand même
qu'on reparlera de Versailles dans dans
les dans les années à venir et sur ce
plateau à plusieurs reprises je crois
dans les dans les années à venir budget
recrutement léché mais aussi progression
sur cette saison on l'a senti sur les
deux matchs dans les derbiers Vinois
face à plaisir un match aller où
Versailles avait été vraiment voilà pas
trop existé face à plaisir et justement
on retourne à Porchefontaine il y avait
eu match entre les deux équipes on a
senti que c'était la saison de la
progression moi je les ai vu à
Ris-Orangis puisque je suis un tout
petit peu resangé je suis juste à côté
ils sont dans la même poule bon il y
avait le Havre qui était au-dessus dans
la poule c'est vrai bon qu'on peut voir
quand même pas mal tu as fait des
remontées mais je trouve que c'était
assez bon il y a eu aussi le le souci de
domo qui a des carrés forfait général
c'est c'est pas bon cela c'est voilà
c'est pas c'est la conduite c'est
difficile
ouais ouais que le budget ne fait pas
tout voilà le budget fait pas tout et
quand même un forfait dès le 4e ou 5e ou
5e match si j'avais bon une poule quand
même où il y avait beaucoup de beaucoup
de Franciliens quand même qu'il y avait
la CBB il y avait d'autres aussi avec
des clubs bretons comme le enfin le rôle
aussi qui était dans le dans le non je
trouve que c'est que c'est bien ils
finissent ils finissent 6e 6e tranquille
par rapport au septième ils ont de
l'avance sur le 7e il y a deux
championnats il y avait
deux voilà et mais ils ont bien voilà je
trouve ça déjà très rapidement et je
voudrais quand même souligner qui sont
ils ont perdu au Creusot au Creusot qui
est une équipe habituée de fédéral où
les thèmes de sa poule où il est tous
les il a été depuis toujours depuis la
nuit des temps
visible à les gagner dans ces régions là
principalement au Creusot moche qui est
quand même une référence des matchs à
domicile donc c'était quand même un bel
exploit votre avis Audrey et alors aussi
ce qui est mis en avant au Rugby Club de
Versailles c'est que malgré les
ambitions il y a toujours cette ambiance
familiale aussi ça c'est aussi reconnu
Versailles je pense que c'est une belle
fierté pour pour Versailles et puis
effectivement comme on dit c'était comme
une belle place sur Le Creusot on dit
pour gagner que ça va perdre mais ce
n'est que porteur de bonne de bon match
à mon avis au vu de ce qu'elle a pu dire
Pierre-Jean et Philippe effectivement
cette cet esprit familial on en a besoin
encore plus aujourd'hui et encore plus
demain donc évidemment on attend la
suite des prochains matchs j'espère
qu'il y aura peut-être sûrement des
sponsors peut-être un peu plus peut-être
on imagine c'est le travail c'est en
bonne voie effectivement le on parlait
de budget donc le budget c'est grâce en
numéro 1 à notre partenaire principal
institutionnel qui est la ville de
Versailles avec les installations de la
ville que de terrain pour un club de 600
650 licenciés c'est souvent peu pour
pouvoir faire tourner tout le monde mais
on ne se plaint pas en se plaint pas
pour autant et effectivement c'est une
partie une grosse partie dédiée au privé
avec des partenaires de plus en plus
nombreux qui nous rejoignent on a une
vraie là aussi un vrai esprit de famille
se regroupant autour de ces fameuses
valeurs de l'Ovalie
avec des événements récurrents pour nos
partenaires et puis cette possibilité de
communiquer autour de l'image du RCV que
l'on veut la plus la plus porteuse
possible et puis en fait on voit on voit
assez souvent que dans le dans le
business les les points de convergence
entre le rugby et les modes de
management et les modes de engagement et
de performance sont souvent analogues
donc que Dieu vous entendent
très rapidement est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à du chamboulement pour la
saison prochaine est-ce que par exemple
le coach va rester Tiffany Charles tout
à fait il y a on peut dire que de toute
façon dans le sport amateur et comme
professionnel il y a des fans de cycles
donc il y aura du changement il y aura
quelques changements d'ici le début de
la saison prochaine qui sont qui se font
de la manière la plus naturelle possible
quelques nouvelles arrivées dans le
staff côté joueur on démarre juste là
maintenant à regarder ce qui se passe à
côté maintenant qu'on sait ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur avec la formation on
va regarder un petit peu ce qui ceux qui
sont disponibles et surtout qui
s'inscrivent comme gens l'a rappelé qui
s'inscrivent dans un état d'esprit et
dans une dans un ciblage qui va avec la
coloration bleue et blanche de
Versailles on se fait en tout cas bon
courage pour la saison prochaine au RCV
bravo pour cette saison et on l'a
compris le club va revenir encore plus
fort la saison prochaine toujours la
fédéral 2 mais on va parler de plaisir
également engagé dans les phases finales
on va remonter le fil tout d'abord le 30
avril dernier les plaisirs rois
recevaient saint-clau du comité de
Franche-Comté embarrage de fédéral 2 une
confrontation qui s'est joué sur un
match en première période l'enjeu semble
avoir galvaniser les Yvelinois il
déroule et même 24 à 0 en seulement 22
minutes de jeu il géreront cet avantage
et vont l'emporter 37 à 23 avec des
essais concédés à la fin du match ça
c'était le 30 avril et dimanche dernier
on était donc le 7 mai plaisir recevait
Saint-Priest pour les 16e de finale
alors c'est un match équilibré sur le
papier les plaisirs ce sont inclinés 18
10 avec une antenne de seconde période
qui a été déterminante dans ce 16e de
finale très serré puisque entre les deux
équipes à la mi-temps il y avait 10 à 10
plaisirs étaient en position favorable
pour marque pour marquer un essai mais
les lieux de Saint-Priest interceptent
et amener ce contre assassin alors je
sais pas si on l'a vu si il s'est
affiché mais en tout cas c'est ça qui a
été déterminant dans le match donc les
plaisirs vont jouer la suite de leur
aventure pour tenter d'accéder à la
suite de ces phases finales d'accession
en Fédérale une lors du match retour qui
est prévu ce dimanche 14 mai dans la
banlieue lyonnaise on va écouter les
réactions d'après match collectées par
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
encore une fois l'adage
c'est valorisé aujourd'hui pour nous
malheureusement au niveau de
l'implication des gars il y a
strictement rien à dire par contre en
terme de maîtrise effectivement on a on
n'a pas su conclure dans les zones de
marque et on savait très bien que
notamment phase finale ça fait la
différence donc ça c'est vraiment
dommage maintenant maintenant il y a
quand même de très bonnes choses à
retenir donc voilà on sait que on sait
que c'est pas fini on a vu ce qu'on
était capable de faire face à cette
équipe donc bon bah c'est tout donner
sur le retour état d'esprit de
conquérant il va falloir aller là en
plus on a du retard on part avec -8 - 8
points donc voilà esprit de conquête et
puis de surtout se faire plaisir parce
que là aujourd'hui on s'est pas fait
plaisir du tout
alors la question après ce match est-ce
que plaisir peut sans vouloir sur cette
rencontre allée au vu de la physionomie
on l'a dit 10 partout à la mi-temps
oui pour Jean
allez vous êtes tous sur du oui bah je
vais vous donner la parole vous gens qui
connaissent très bien ce club de plaisir
avec s'entraîneur de du club
vous on peut s'en vouloir après après
s'être rencontre même si voilà tout est
jouable encore tout est ouvert pour pour
la rencontre toi j'ai pas participé au
match oui bien sûr j'ai vu les images 18
10 avec une interception de 80 mètres 90
mètres même c'est quasiment un plaisir
qui est sur le point de marquer et une
interception c'est toujours c'est
toujours ah ça c'est maintenant
j'ai eu juste quelques quelques images
et sur les échos que j'ai eu moi je mets
un ticket on en reparlera je mets un
ticket qu'ils iront se qualifier à
Saint-Priest on en reparlera moi je dis
qu'ils vont aller gagner là-bas ils vont
aller gagner là-bas parce que
je pense qu'ils ont fait ils ont eu de
fait preuve de beaucoup de malchance sur
ce match là beaucoup de peut-être de de
de petits détails de petites fautes
techniques faute de main un moment où
ils étaient sur des des moments forts
ils ont ils ont fait quelque fautes
inhabituelles et peut-être que aussi
l'enjeu la pression puisque pour eux
c'est aussi la la première fois qu'ils
font les phases finales de Fédérale 2
Faut faut faut le dire aussi c'est la
première fois qu'ils sont à ce niveau-là
donc il y a peut-être aussi une petite
une certaine appréhension une certaine
pression
mais comme l'a dit Sébastien roncali à
son interview ils vont tout jouer ils se
sont dans ces moments-là moi je suis
entraîneur donc dans ce moment-là faut
surtout pas retenir ses joueurs faut
leur dire de toute façon si on tente pas
aujourd'hui la seule chose qui peut nous
arriver c'est gagner donc si on perd
c'est fini donc il faut il faut il faut
vraiment y aller à fond et moi je vous
le dis je le répète je mets un ticket on
regardera dimanche soir qui avait raison
je vais indiquer sur le plaisir et je
pense qu'ils iront gagner à Saint-Priest
votre avis Philippe avec une rencontre
qui jouera cette fois-ci à l'extérieur
pour les que je souhaite
mais
c'est sûr que au vu des images c'était
quand même il pouvait aussi bien
inverser le score inverser le score et
bon savoir aussi que Saint-Priest ils
ont vaincu chez eux même s'ils sont à
vaincus chez eux de toute la saison ils
ont juste un match qui était serré
autrement ils ont gagné à l'aise bon
après ça veut rien dire parce que comme
disait Jean
ils savent que grand plaisir c'est le
dernier match voilà si donne tout ça
peut ça peut le faire on y croit on y
croit vous y croyez également
j'allais mettre la même pièce que Jean
parce que on en a suffisamment parlé ici
et puis on les a vu évoluer surtout
cette saison vraiment dans le dans la
même poule et déjà depuis quelques
saisons c'est une des saisons de la
maturité pour pour plaisir qui est déjà
qui est là maintenant bien ancrée en
Fédérale 2 qui a connu a connu la
fédérale 2 d'avant d'accord avec Jean
pour dire que c'est très fort mais là
elle a fait par l'univers vers le haut à
un petit peu édulcoré les niveaux
sportifs et la fédérale 2 de cette année
correspond à une grosse Fédérale 3 de
l'année dernière donc
non seulement ils sont à leur place et
là ils travaillent là aussi dans la
durée et donc c'est c'est maintenant ou
jamais des regrets c'est toute la saveur
du de des phases finales au rugby on en
a toujours quand on a un match à la
comme ça à domicile pour démarrer et
qu'on est à -8 mais il y a eu des
remontes d'Ada qui celui qui ont qui
sont partis de beaucoup plus loin même
et là dans l'état d'esprit ça a l'air
d'être salaire d'être le cas il se
dissouts qui sont passés à côté du match
malchance en plus cette interception qui
fait qui qui inverse le cours du match
au moment où au plaisir était en
position de marquer et effectivement
cette Maintenon voilà cette maturité
sans doute cette expérience qu'ils ont
accumulé pendant ces 6 7 7 dernières
saisons et qui peut leur permettre
d'aller faire un coup à Saint-Priest il
y a une vraie différence entre les de
fédéral 2 comme c'est le cas en fédéral
3 on se rend compte que les niveaux sont
assez disparate on l'a vu nous on l'a vu
en barrage donc il y a un coup il y a un
coup à jouer et qu'ils aillent pour
rebondir sur ce que ce film disait les
matchs de se faire plaisir non rien à
voir les matchs
je vous rappelle quand même que que
plaisir a battu le Havre qui était le
qui est le le gros morceau de la poule
cette année et ils sont ils l'ont mis je
crois même et ils ont remis le bois
plaisir donc les matchs du match de
poule n'ont rien à voir un match de
phase finale c'est à dire c'est une zone
compétition l'état d'esprit est
complètement différent et il y a surtout
surtout là sur le match retour qui va
être le match coupé
Saint-Priest va avoir la peur de gagner
face à une équipe de plaisir qui a les
moyens techniques et physiques moi je
les ai vu jouer j'ai pas vu le match là
j'ai vu jouer à Orsay pour pour le
dernier match de championnat ils ont les
moyens techniques et physiques d'aller
leur mettre à la misère et je je
maintiens ici j'espère que mon bas me
faire mentir mais je vais être ici qui
passeront le mental il sera pour
beaucoup pour cette rencontre je pense
qu'on peut mettre tous un ticket tout
simplement et toujours pour le plaisir
mais vous risquez dire genre je pense
qu'on peut y croire
un message au capitaine François
Levillain pour pour pas qu'il me faut un
dernier choix dernier exemple en date
c'est après le match contre Versailles
le Creusot à domicile toujours en match
aller en 32e c'est
ne c'est incliné que d'un point face à
Courbevoie un 31 32 et on pouvait penser
que que Courbevoie allait se balader
parce que c'est une des belles équipes
de cette pour 8 et phase finale match à
domicile et Le Creusot dur à prendre
d'un point donc ils perdent perdre la
domicile mais et là là à nouveau tout
est ouvert sur le match retour en tout
cas on a une équipe de plaisir qui est
bien soudée le groupe du bien on va
regarder justement leur joie c'était
juste après le match en barrage face à
Saint-Cloud après leur victoire dans les
vestiaires regardez
[Applaudissements]
peut-être un dernier tour de table très
rapide un groupe qui vit bien on est
aussi dans un club qui travaille bien on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'importance
des jeunes pierre il s'est aussi un une
équipe un club qui mise énormément sur
sur son secteur jeune et surtout rugby
l'esprit l'esprit d'équipe et le
collectif est essentiel au rugby on peut
gagner n'importe quel type de match par
ce biais là
un dernier mot oui plaisir plaisir je
dirais la différence qui peut y avoir
entre le club de plaisir et celui de
Versailles celui de Versailles veut
aller très très vite il veut mettre les
moyens les gros moyens très vite pour
aller pour aller accéder de suite plus
haut alors que plaisir travaille
beaucoup plus sur la longueur parce que
les moyens déjà sont pas les mêmes les
moyens financiers je parle ils n'ont pas
ils n'ont pas le même budget et il
travaille énormément sur la longueur et
justement sur cet état d'esprit qui est
vraiment cet état d'esprit famille très
familier parce que le plaisir c'est ça
c'est très famille et il y a quand même
très peu d'éléments extérieure qui est
qui est injecté alors c'est très ciblé
parce que il y a très peu de joueurs qui
arrivent à l'intersaison il s'est juste
pour remplacer des éventuels départ mais
ils gardent toujours l'ossature moi ça
fait la montée en Fédérale 2 s'il y a
5-6 ans il y a 6 ans il y a encore il y
a encore un tiers des joueurs plus d'un
tiers des joueurs que que j'ai entraîné
que je connais qui qui forme encore et
qui première donc c'est dans les c'est
la preuve
il trouve il trouve il trouve leur
bonheur dans la dans la continuité et
dans le temps moi souhaiter bonne chance
à plaisir qui jouera donc son match
retour face à Saint-Priest ce 14 mai on
espère bien sûr une qualification pour
nos plaisirs on va passer maintenant à
notre page débat
[Musique]
et parler d'un sujet qui nous fait trop
souvent réagir en plateau je veux bien
si bien sûr parler du Paris
Saint-Germain ça va mal pour le club qui
s'entraîne dans les Yvelines
actuellement à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
bientôt du côté de la commune de Poissy
Lionel Messi a été sanctionné récemment
de deux semaines de suspension du coup
par les dirigeants parisiens pour être
allé en Arabie Saoudite sans l'accord de
son club sur un jour qui n'était pas un
jour de repos il n'a pas pu jouer alors
il ne peut pas jouer pendant deux
semaines même si les revenus très
récemment à l'entraînement c'est une
nouvelle qu'on a eu en début de semaine
du côté du Paris Saint-Germain il a dit
qu'il ne savait pas que c'était un jour
d'entraînement tout simplement qu'il
avait programmé son voyage en avance en
sachant qu'après des jouets les matchs
les matchs de championnats il y avait
des jours de repos programmés déjà une
petite réaction Philippe au sur cette
affaire Messi alors le club parisien
qu'on a à qui on a souvent reproché de
de ne pas être de ne pas avoir la poigne
avec ses joueurs là a fait preuve
justement
d'autorité dans ce cas mais si qu'est-ce
que ça vous inspire bah ça m'inspire que
je dans ce cas là je pense qu'il fallait
pas le faire
donc voilà c'est c'est non pas parce que
c'est Messi c'est pas le bon moment ça
aurait dû le faire avant même si ils
l'ont déjà fait avec Aurier ils l'ont
déjà fait il y a quelques années avec
oreiller mais là c'est après ça bien sûr
mais déjà dites-moi ça c'est le plus
grand joueur du monde on n'a pas à lui
faire ça on n'a pas tout le monde ça a
vraiment fait du buzz du buzz partout en
plus là la cerise sur le gâteau c'est
quand même je veux dire son interview en
début de semaine qui s'excusait on
aurait dit un petit garçon qui
s'excusait
il attendait de voir ce que ce qu'elle
allait faire le Paris-Saint-Germain de
lui mais quand même avec après ces
excuses qui ont que peut-être le PG
qu'on lui demande qui l'ont demandé de
le faire il est réintégré et je suis sûr
que le contrajaccio il va il va rejouer
ça c'est pratiquement pratiquement
certain après il savait pas parce que
d'habitude ils ont un jour de repos
après un match vous avez joué à Angers
20 ans contre
Lorient
lorientait pas le jour de repos derrière
parce que j'étais au match c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment une parodie de
une parodie de football donc voilà c'est
que c'était prévu largement en avance et
puis il faut respecter l'engagement et
il est parti et puis voilà il disait
peut-être qu'il voit rien mais c'est un
peu c'est l'année de c'est l'année alors
juste préciser que cette sanction qui
finalement il y a une réintégration de
la part de Messi va le pousser
vraisemblablement vers la sortie à lui
qui est en fin de contrat en juin
prochain on dit qu'il pourrait retourner
à Barcelone on parle même de plus en
plus de d'un avenir doré en Arabie
saoudite à plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros par le même du milliard
pour le contrat qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire est-ce que il fallait faire ça à
Messi on a parlé d'humiliation aussi
dans la presse pour un conceptible le
Ballon d'Or quand même en fait c'est la
délégation Argentine partout en France
et dans le monde qui s'est offusqué de
cette de cette sanction là
je je suis assez d'accord avec Philippe
sur sur le fait de dire que c'est c'est
en fait disproportionné dans le temps on
a un calendrier qui est assez qui est
posé assez longtemps à l'avance par
habitude effectivement les pros ont une
journée de off après après un match qui
joue le dimanche donc c'était programmer
ce lundi-là apparemment c'était un
voyage que Messi avait déjà prévu aidé
déjà décalé plusieurs fois
sportivement on va dire par rapport à
ses obligations
d'une manière générale il est temps que
cette saison se termine pour le PSG
souhaitons quand même qu'elle se termine
par un titre de champion de France qui
est pas encore fait qui est pas encore
fait malgré tout parce que ça pousse ça
pousse encore derrière mais l'état
d'esprit n'y est plus du tout du tout on
a des supporters qui grondent de partout
et que que cette phase star system se
termine
parce que on l'a déjà dit pour d'autres
pour d'autres équipes ou d'autres sports
ça ne suffit pas d'empiler les stars il
faut qu'elles apprennent à jouer
ensemble et quand le M&M marche pas
forcément très très bien depuis le début
de la saison dès qu'on
il est temps que ça se termine et qu'on
revienne à l'esprit qui a fait l'esprit
combatif qui a fait qui a fait la gloire
de des années parisiennes puisqu'on voit
que là le QSI n'y arrive pas forcément
aller ne serait-ce que gagner une ligue
des champions Messi a marqué 6 buts pour
sa première année en Ligue 1 il en a
marqué 15 cette année il a fait
également 14 paces des 6 pour sa
première année 15 pour la seconde et ce
n'est pas fini en Ligue des Champions il
a marqué 5 et 4 buts donc sur le plan
comptable on est plutôt bon je vais
écouter votre avis Audrey et Jean j'ai
juste vous poser la question vous allez
lever la petite raquette est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une fiasco la venue de
Messi au Paris Saint-Germain à votre
avis lui qui est arrivé il y a deux
saisons
un peu fort c'est un peu fort donc vous
êtes plutôt sur le nom et je vais quand
même écouter votre avis sur sur cette
affaire Messi et peut-être me dire
pourquoi à votre avis ce n'est pas un
fiasco la technique ici il y a plusieurs
choses tout d'abord Lionel Messi c'est
quand même un très grand joueur donc
évidemment moi je suis toujours
impressionné par son jeu moi le carton
rouge simplement c'est il y a des règles
du jeu c'est comme sport si on ne
respecte pas les règles ces cartons
rouges donc là clairement c'est pour ça
que je mets ce carton rouge après voilà
le PSG c'est quand même une image de
marque il faut la redorer il faut
peut-être la reconstruire revoir une
autre teinte de vision donc il y a
vraiment toute une dont tu parlais
effectivement pierre sur le PSG Lionel
Messi je pense qu'à mon nez faut pas non
plus avoir la grosse tête pour revenir
un petit plus
respecter son engagement avec le Paris
Saint-Germain avant celui avec l'Arabie
Saoudite oui puis même quand on voit les
les jeunes qui sont complètement Fab
enfin comment dire fan de de Messi il y
a une image et puis aussi des règles du
jeu donc il prendra le choix mais le
choix qui prendra va être aussi
fatidique sur la suite des choses
notamment sur le PSG mais sur la sur
l'image de marque sur aussi les joueurs
donc oui carton rouge sur ce sujet là
toute l'histoire autour de Neymar il y a
en ce moment au PSG c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de Rumes ménage des supporters
qui sont venus notamment peut-être voir
les images manifester devant devant sa
maison à Bougival c'était très affectif
ambiance très tendu au PSG autour de
Neymar et autour de la pharmacie genre
oui bon elle est mort elle a l'habitude
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça moi je
trouve je trouve que c'est un petit peu
démesuré par rapport à toutes les
phrases que peut faire un joueur comme
comme Neymar durant toute la saison où
on est quand même où le PSG on n'est pas
moi parce que c'était comment ça va être
réglé mais où le le les dirigeants du
PSG sont quand même assez assez lâches
avec enfin lâche l'as de de avec un mec
comme les mains la Messie qui fait pas
trop parler de lui je veux dire
dans le mauvais sens du terme il a été
quand même il a été quand même
tranquille quoi cette saison là il y a
six sport là on voudrait le virer on
voudrait le pousser vers la sortie on
sait pas aussi prendre pas mieux j'ai
l'impression qu'on profite un peu de de
de ce petit écart pour qu'il y a un
prétexte que parce que c'est quand même
pas non plus à comparer de ce que
l'autre a fait de ce que Neymar a fait
c'est que dalle c'est ce qu'il a fait
d'autant plus que c'est un contrat qu'il
a avec le la compagnie aérienne mais si
un contrat de publicité donc le PSG est
au courant de ça
à la vue de à la vue du joueur et de son
comportement je trouve que c'est un
petit peu exagéré que c'est un petit peu
trop amplifié et moi moi je vois je vois
ça comme le fait de dire mais si on
pouvait profiter de l'occasion pour le
pousser vers la sortie récupérer un peu
de monnaie pour aller chercher d'autres
gars et puis ce débarrasser on arrive
pas à se débarrasser du du du foulard
qui saute de partout on va essayer de se
débarrasser du petit qui parle pas
beaucoup ce serait moi pour moi c'est
voilà je trouve ça un petit peu déplacé
bon il y a beaucoup à dire sur cette
affaire PSG le mot de la fin très
rapidement
au PSG pour le match de contrat Ajaccio
même si on n'aime pas trop les mages qui
font il y a la finale de l'orange
Football Challenge féminine à la
mi-temps et il y a une équipe de des
Yvelines c'est fontaine fleurie qui va
jouer contre la CBB la finale féminine à
la mi-temps donc de Pays d'Ajaccio
samedi prochain
ouais très bien voilà la suite au
prochain épisode pour le PSG à Paris qui
normalement sans sauve grosse surprise
de vrai remporter son nouveau titre de
champion de France dans les prochaines
semaines on parlera dans une prochaine
émission de la carrière de Tom Smith
talon de l'enduro c'est de la moto on
aura l'occasion d'en parler dans une
prochaine émission mais je voulais
terminer nous reste 3 minutes sur du
baseball et cet hommage qui a été rendu
par les cougars il y a quelques jours en
hommage à Annie Couton décédé en en
octobre dernier la mémoire de l'ancienne
président du club de baseball était
célébré ce dimanche 30 avril au complexe
sportif Jean maréchal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux à l'occasion d'un
match contre Rouen une plaque
commémorative a été révélée pour honorer
la mémoire de celle qui a porté les
cougars jusqu'en division 1 de baseball
on écoute le nouveau président du club
José droger au micro de TV 78 c'est
quelqu'un qui a resté à la tête du club
pendant très longtemps qui a su le
développer aussi pour être le club qu'il
est aujourd'hui donc oui en tant que
nouveau président bon ça c'est un défi
et puis aussi c'est c'est une source
d'inspiration pour pour aller plus loin
et pour porter le club encore plus haut
votre avis sur cet hommage on va
terminer avec un hommage dans dans le 7
8 Audrey
en fait j'encourage toujours les
nouvelles venus c'est vrai c'est jamais
évident de partir sur quelque chose qui
a été vraiment très très fort avant donc
si je suis toujours très positive dans
ce sens là d'encourager et puis et puis
c'est vrai que on a toujours on a
toujours comparer mais on peut comparer
ce qui n'est pas comparable donc je ne
fais que positiver les choses j'ai dit
dans le statut on est bien sûr dans le
si on parlait sport c'est l'habitude de
présenter d'autres émissions elle a
réussi pierre way à faire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les cougar de
Montigny un top club en terme de
baseball en France on a on a peu de peu
d'occasions de marquer un sport qui plus
est un sport confidentiel comme il l'est
en France avec le baseball on en parle
de temps en temps avec le foot US c'est
et donc le baseball donc le l'hommage
l'hommage est évident puisque ça permet
justement d'honorer son d'honorer sa
mémoire et le travail le travail réussi
ou tenté et réussi sur ces années pour
les et de les faire exister ne serait-ce
que d'un point de vue médiatique
entre 2008 et 2018 Philippe votre avis
sur sur cet hommage un bel hommage c'est
tout à fait c'est tout à fait normal je
dis de faire cette heureuse comme vous
le disant en tant que Présidente c'est
pas mal et puis ça ça aussi ben ça
montre le club aussi parce que on entend
pas énormément parler et ça montre voilà
moi je suis c'est bien parce qu'ils ont
fait une plaque commémorative il y a
aussi le stade qui va être renommée en
son nom c'est c'est voilà lui faire le
plus bel honneur qu'on pouvait le plus
bel hommage qu'on pouvait du côté de
Montigny un coup de chapeau un goût de
chapeau belle hommage et je pense que
c'est c'est justifié
assez proche bien sûr en écoutant qui
était venu plusieurs fois sur le plateau
de TV 78 et qui est aujourd'hui bien sûr
disparu voilà c'est déjà à la fin de ce
si on parlait sport ça va j'ai été bon
dans ma la première vous m'avez
de Michael et Miro que j'ai récupéré au
dernier moment donc la prochaine fois on
jaugera vraiment sur cette émission et
on va terminer comme d'habitude parce
que nickel on a l'habitude avec une
situation un site citation d'un joueur
de football et on parlait de Lionel
Messi à tout à l'heure vous devez vous
battre pour atteindre votre rêve vous
devez vous sacrifier et travailler dur
pour cela cela me préoccupe davantage
d'être une bonne personne plutôt que
d'être le meilleur joueur du monde je
vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase et
à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]